seventy years ago on november 20th 1945
international war crimes trials began in
nuremberg germany next on american
history tv historian mark hull gives an
illustrated talk about the einstein's
group in case held before a u.s military
court beginning in september 1947.
in this eight-month proceeding 24
commanders of nazi ss mobile killing
units were tried for murdering more than
one million jews and tens of thousands
of others including partisan fighters
disabled persons and roma the national
archives at kansas city hosted this
hour-long talk
this evening we mark the 70th
anniversary of the nuremberg trials as
we present our program in partnership
with the truman presidential library
the truman center at the university of
missouri-kansas city the midwest center
for holocaust education and the u.s army
command and general staff college
tonight's program speaker dr mark hull
is an associate professor at the command
and general staff college at fort
leavenworth kansas where he teaches the
advanced trial course war crimes law and
history he earned his undergraduate
degree from the citadel
his doctorate from the university
college cork in ireland and juris
doctorate from the cumberland school of
law
prior to teaching at the cgsc dr hall
worked as a criminal prosecutor and
served as a brigade intelligence advisor
with the u.s army military transition
team
from 2006 to 2007 in iraq
his books include irish secrets german
espionage and wartime ireland and he has
written numerous articles and reviews on
various topics ranging from prosecuting
persecuting
war crimes to military intelligence he
is an elected fellow at the of the royal
historical society please join me in
welcoming dr mark hall this evening
thank you
uh thank you and welcome
i'm kind of glad they scheduled this
talk tonight rather than during the
world series because i have a feeling
that most of you would probably not be
here
um
the talk i'm going to give tonight is
the nature of it can be complex uh i'm
going to try to keep it from being
disturbing but it is serious and
i'd like you to imagine me tonight as a
lawyer trying to make a case
and the case i'm going to try to make to
you is why this is profound i think why
it's important
and why you should think it's just as
important maybe more important in 2015
as the trial was in 1948 when it
finished
in fairness though i should probably
tell you a story
last year i had the honor of going to
nuremberg
and for somebody who does a lawyer who
does nuremberg trial stuff this was
wonderful
i was the guest of a bavarian supreme
court justice and i got to go to
courtroom 600
and spend time just there
we went around i got to look at at the
place where this trial happened
and after we were finished we went to
the back room which is the one on the
the right hand side there
and it's where the justices gathered
after the trial to consider their
verdicts
and i sat down and the justice judge
brought me over
a book and it was the distinguished
visitors book from the palace of justice
and i'm looking through and it's got
prosecutors and presidents and and
people have signed this thing there's
some incredible signatures in it
and she said to me well i'd appreciate
if you'd write something
and i froze
because i had nothing it's sort of like
if you can you do profound on you know
click of your fingers and i had nothing
and i'm figuring you know
be cool
best wishes dr h is probably not going
to get the job done
so while i'm trying desperately and i
just have this this this deer in the
headlights panic
i think okay i can buy myself a couple
extra seconds and what i'll do is i'll
write this with my fountain pen
and that plan starts to go okay until i
look down at my hand and realize the pen
has exploded
and i have ink all over my hand and i'm
getting ready to put this down on the
distinguished visitors book from the
palace of justice at this place that
i've wanted to be for my whole life
and the moral of the story here is if
you're expecting me to be profound you
may go home with ink in your hands
i guarantee nothing
uh the trials specifically the the
subsequent trials are distinguished from
the main military trial of the
international tribunal
a lot of people don't know that one even
happened
and if you you can find people that know
the imt occurred was 45 to 46 is where
gehring was tried is where hess was
tried is where sparrow was tried
the chances of you finding somebody that
knows that there were 12 trials
afterward is pretty remote
and i'm going to pick what i think is
the most significant of these
specifically to talk about tonight the
einsatzgruppen case
for a variety of reasons
[Applause]
that's the main imt
uh gehring is seated at the far left
it is an international tribunal
organized by the out four great allied
powers the u.s the soviet union great
britain and france
it's
the one that drew the most attention
it revealed for the first time the
degree in the extent of nazi crimes
during world war ii
and the trial has a lot of different
purposes one of the purposes is
educational it's supposed to tell people
what happened with documentary evidence
in a judicial legalistic
format
other part is perhaps political
it's designed as a springboard to the
new united nations
it's designed as a vehicle to help a new
germany take the place of the germany
that's just been destroyed
it's designed to set again a documentary
record so that anytime after 1946 no one
with a right mind can ever deny what
happened
during the war
but when the trial finishes in 46
the sec second set of trials occurs
and
there's two figures in particular that
again most people have never heard of
if you start to think about great
or famous american trial lawyers you
probably heard of clarence
darrow everybody's heard of clarence
darrow
clarence daryl again is probably the
most famous trial lawyer we've ever
produced
i think one of the best is the guy on
the left here telford taylor
general taylor
he was a prosecutor at the main trial at
the imt
and he's the architect and sort of the
founding father of the 12 subsequent
trials
so the stuff that we talk about tonight
is going to be largely the result of
taylor's vision
and his insistence on some of these
things coming out
he's also somebody of extraordinary
moral courage he's one of a handful of
people that in the 50s under mccarthy
he probably caused himself a supreme
court judgeship or justiceship
because he spoke out
the other guy guy on the right is ben
ference
ben was the prosecutor at the
einsatzgruppen case
when he took the case he was 27 years
old
he'd never tried a case in his life
he'd never been in a courtroom before
and we made him the chief prosecutor for
the army for the onshot scripting case
he's also one of the kindest most
generous people i've ever met
ben is 95 he's still alive
he is sharp
and has a better memory and better
recall than i'll probably ever have the
rest of my life
just a good guy great lawyer
and he also is one of the architects of
what we're going to be talking about
[Music]
when i do my classes for war crimes
i show them this picture
and it's one of the most terrifying
things i think i've probably ever seen
and it's terrifying in a lot of
different ways
the picture is taken
in the southern ukraine in september
1941
the person the nco there with the pistol
who's about ready to kill this man is a
member of what's called einstein's group
of d
everybody all the other jews of a town
called fenitsa are laying in the ditch
in front of him
there's about thirty thousand of them
the
s the the einsatz group of the sd
thought this was so singular
that to capture the moment of execution
of the last of the jews of finnitza
that the slogan on the back is the
lester youth von finisa the last jew of
vanessa
and again it's it's a horrible thing
it's horrible for the person who knows
what's going to happen because he sees
everybody in front of him is dead
but just as scary to me
in a lot of other respects are the
people in the background
you have members of the einsatz group
are there
you have members of the german army that
are there there's a guy
second to left front row he's in the
german army band
you have members of the reich labor
service the people you don't see in the
picture that would have also have been
there are people from the local village
who came out just to watch
it's it's a terrible thing
and it's to my mind sort of
narrows the scope of of what happened
and what we're going to be talking about
the reason the onsite script case
happened
occurred
uh of the 12 trials that are planned
after the main imt trial
something happened during the main trial
that made this almost inevitable
one of the prosecution witnesses is an
ss general named otto olendorf this
guy he was captured by the british in
1945
he talked absolutely freely
of what happened during the war
and what he did he commanded one of the
einsatzgruppe
his testimony was used by the
prosecution with olendorf's cooperation
during the main trial against the other
german defendants
he testified on the stand that his eins
einsatz group had murdered ninety
thousand people
he's upset at one point because another
einsatz group a commander had claimed
more people murdered and olendorf is
saying no he's just exaggerating i kill
many more people than he did
so with olendorf's testimony on the
record
you had the beginnings of a case that
could be devoted entirely to the einsatz
group because after at this point the
americans and the british really had
decided
that joint power
trials are probably not something we
want to be involved in
so the decision was made for the allies
to separate the judicial process and
they're going to continue to try war
criminals but separately
so the 12 subsequent trials the doctor's
trial the ige farben trial the
ministries trial the high command trial
the einsteins group at trial
are going to be entirely under american
and specifically american army
jurisdiction
but olendorf and we're going to see him
again
is going to be a continuing participant
in the story
because there's something
disquieting about who he is
that i want to come back to at the end
when we talk about i think why this
trial is important
now combined with olendor's testimony
during the main trial this occurred in
early 1946
the
lawyer
ben ference who had actually he had been
enlisted in the army he had been
discharged in 1945 gone back
he was a harvard graduate
uh had been recruited to come back and
work for the army for the office of war
crimes
in berlin
while he's in the berlin documentation
center which is where we brought all the
captured nazi documentation ss records
party records foreign service records
everything
he's looking through the records
which is no easy task because there are
tons and tons of them and of course none
of them are in english they're all in
german
he uncovers the
reports sent back by the different
einsatzgrupa from the east
and ben says that he started he he
actually once he started looking at the
figures in the tabulation he wouldn't
got a calculator
hand calculator
and when he reached a total of a million
people
he called taylor
and this the combination of olendor's
testimony at the imt plus ben ference's
discovery of these documents
is what made the is group a case
mandatory
now
the way the case is organized is kind of
interesting
and the legal philosophy is unique in a
prosecution or at least i've never heard
of one never been involved in one would
whichever did this
this trial last eight months from
september 1947 to april 1948.
out of all those days of testimony
the prosecution takes two days
they put on no witnesses
think about every courtroom drama you've
ever seen i mean that's part of that's
part of the thing right i mean you
direct you cross you do stuff
that's not happening here
the only people on the stand for the
prosecution are the documents custodians
that are reading into the record
the the the sd or einsatz group of
reports of which there are many
and the testimony of people who
testified either during interrogation
were testified at the main trial
so what the as far as the prosecution's
case is concerned the eins out group
trial turns into a cross-examination
fest
and for trial lawyer this is just like
the coolest thing ever
and i've been advised by the way that
there are things that trial lawyers find
cool that normal people don't find cool
[Music]
but this this really is and the idea of
you don't have to worry about you know
direct testimony and prepping prepping
that but you have to be prepared to
cross-examine
every one of the defendants assuming to
testify
the procedure with the int and with the
subsequent trials is a little bit
different than maybe you're used to
defendants do not have to testify
but defendants also are interrogated and
interviewed before
as soon as they're captured and there's
no attorney present
they talk freely
for different purposes
and here in a few minutes we'll talk
about sort of the categories i think
their defenses broke down into and some
of these are very
interesting because one of the things
that
has puzzled me and still puzzles me
is how you get people to commit the
crimes that these people have committed
in fact i suspect probably on a greater
scale than even been ference could prove
the onset group that were formed at
first in the invasion of poland in 1939.
there were seven of them uh the einsatz
groupen it's collect it's a collective
noun
uh the einsatz grupa were numbered one
through seven but by the time the
invasion of russia happens actually a
little bit before the invasion of russia
there are four einsatz group a b c and d
heydrich who is the chief of the sd and
heinrich himmler's deputy is the the guy
running point for the einsatzgruppe
they're assigned to german army
commands
so army group a in the north has
einstein's group a
army group b einstein's group of b and
so forth einstein's group of d is
assigned to 11th army in the crimea
their mission and their recruiting takes
place again early 1941 before the
invasion
the members of the is group are in every
respect you can imagine
absolutely
ordinary which is one of the things that
makes this thing so difficult
they are trained their task is literally
by the time we get to 1941 to act as
mobile extermination squads to go
wherever they can go in the occupied
soviet union and murder people
they are meticulous record keepers
they will submit actually every three
weeks they submit different reports on
the numbers of jews that have been
killed back to headquarters
i've got this big book sitting on my
desk at work it's called the crime
classification manual
it's prepared by the fbi
and it's designed to for every violent
offense to tell you the kind of offender
you can probably expect
none of these people fit that
any of those categories
they are if you had to pick the kind of
person likely to commit a mass murder
none of these people would fit that
category
of the incest group of leaders
just from einstein's group a you have 17
officers
nine of them have doctorate degrees
you have an opera singer
you have accountants you have lawyers
you have medical doctors that are
serving as head of these mobile
extermination units
what is how do you how does that occur
this isn't the crazy person with a
weapon that you kind of think might do
this sort of thing they're exactly the
kind of people you think would never do
this kind of thing
they're professional none of them have a
criminal record
the ones
that live on later none of them ever
commit a crime there's one exception by
the way one of these guys
how is that even possible
and
the sad truth of it is it's extremely
possible in fact it's even likely
but as you're pre as you're continuing
with the prosecution of the case you're
not
prosecuting the kind of offenders you
normally prosecute these are highly
intelligent highly adaptive smart people
who are going to concoct stories
in most cases to try to obscure the
truth
and as fairness is job you've got to
break that
the one exception to the criminal record
rule
is nalman who is this guy in the bottom
right
he was afraid of being captured by the
americans so he murders his driver and
assumes his identity
the worst of this group certainly
olendorf who's down on the bottom next
to naumann
he's a doctorate of law
he's an economist
everybody who ever met him including the
prosecuting attorneys and the judges
commented how intelligent and
well-spoken and reasonable
all these people are psych tested while
they're in custody
all of them come back normal
the only thing that distinguishes them
is the fact that they all self-selected
for the ss
and you can probably draw some
reasonable conclusions from that you
don't sell you don't volunteer for ss
service unless you're an anti-semite
just like you don't volunteer for free
service in in the ku klux klan unless
you know you hate people
that's the distinction
this is a map of some of not all of the
sites where the einstein's group of
massacres occurred
they're everywhere
and
one of the advantages the prosecution
has when you're using the documents of
the defendants themselves and that and
of course again the beauty of that
strategy is it's impossible for them to
deny this
and even the defendants authenticate the
documents
yes that's my signature
yes that's the report i submitted
yes that total is correct
and fairness also observes too that it
almost seemed that they were offended by
the idea that somehow their math wasn't
right
that that was almost a worse offense
than anything else
the map on the left hand side
accompanied a situation report from
einsatz group a
so
the baltic states northern russia
uh the upper extremity of the map
you wouldn't fry
means there are no more jews left there
and as you go down you can see the
numbers have killed that einstein's
group a is reporting
so from that uh center left section 136
421 and this is just like a normal
situation report
and obviously if you're submitting
reports of this kind in the open you're
not worried about the reception it's
going to get on the other side
this is called the jaeger report it's a
a essentially an an adding to an added
total
uh date by date place by place numbers
of people that are killed
it's
everything it's there for everybody to
see who wants to see it
this has also entered this prosecution
exhibit
and
there was a fascinating book if you
haven't read it you probably should
uh called ordinary men by christopher
browning that came out a while ago
and it documents the experience of a
police battalion 101 in this
extermination campaign in the east
and the question browning asks and again
the question that the trial judge is
going to ask is again what is going to
motivate you why are these people doing
these things
because their photos sent home look just
like snapshots anybody was sent home
except they're taking other kinds of
photographs that aren't in general
circulation and there are a lot of them
the photograph on the left hand side is
from is group of c
uh
the more i looked at this picture the
more something looked kind of weird to
me and the weird thing is the
person standing with her back to you on
the center of the the panel
it's a woman
she's a police reservist
and there's just no end of these and
we're not going to do any more of them
because it's bad enough that this stuff
has to live in my head it doesn't need
to live in yours
but it's absolutely
there's no denying this
this is a scale that is unthinkable and
even unimaginable and is part of the
problem when you're presenting the case
because fairness says at the outset in
the opening statement to to the is group
of
jury or she's been the judges
we're dealing here with a number that is
almost beyond comprehension and it is
beyond comprehension
the senior the judges can make a
difference in any trial
and you have an interesting
one of these here
the senior judge is a guy named michael
musmano
he's from new jersey i'm sort of my bad
pennsylvania
joe that's just for you
he is the kind of judge that trial
lawyers hate
because if he doesn't think you're doing
a good enough job questioning a witness
he's going to take that over for you
if he just wants to know something and
that isn't on part of one of the
questions you'd plan to ask it's okay
he's going he's going to just he's going
to break in and ask the question
and mikey will go on for
a while
meanwhile ben ference or the german
defense attorney is just sitting there
watching you know the train accident
happen and there's really nothing you
can do about it
the two other judges
spite who's from alabama and dixon from
north carolina
if they said anything or made any
contribution to the trial the record
does not reflect it
this is mike musmano's show
he is the center of attention he will
make sure the attention is on him he
talks to the press a lot
uh he goes to the eichmann trial in 1961
to try to sell a new book he's he's
written
the most famous thing with mike mosmano
beside and there and there is some good
stuff here too i mean it's not totally
you know
negative
when the defense is trying to introduce
evidence that frankly is pretty
extraneous and irrelevant
ben ferris objects
and mike musmano gets on his soapbox and
he says listen i will i will allow any
evidence whatsoever
to include the sex life of a penguin
if i think it's relevant
and at the end of the case the german
defense attorneys actually gave him a
small little bronze statue of a penguin
just as a reminder
but he's
he's a difficult personality but on the
positive side one of the things mike
mossmano is trying to do during the
trial is answer the question that a
prosecutor simply probably doesn't care
about
motive
i don't have to prove motive i have to
prove intent
motive is a separate animal motive is
nice if you can do it if you can't it's
fine because the elements of the crime
don't call for it
musmano will ask the same sorts of
questions for each of these 24
defendants that appear at this trial
why what's your belief why did you think
that
and some of them will be evasive
and some of them won't
but he doesn't let them off the hook
until he gets some sort of an answer and
just preserving that on the record is is
an extraordinary achievement and it's
still very useful right now
and to kind of go back to
to the defendants in this case
we start out with 24 that are indicted
why do you think it's 24
this is audience participation night so
you get a chance to say
24 hours of the day
no
but okay
that's
at least partially right because at
least the ones on trial were at least
the senior the senior people that they
could find an arrest
most of them did or at least some of
them did but that's not the answer
either the answer is actually kind of
simple mathematics there are 24 seats in
the defendant's box at nuremberg
so you don't have 25 because otherwise
you get a folding chair and that ain't
going to look very good
so 24 defendants in the main trial
every one of the subsequent trials the
cap is 24 because that's what that's how
many you can see
and as luck would have it again most of
the senior but not all the senior isis
group and people are brought here and
the decision of course is made by the
prosecution we're going to take this
essentially like an organized crime case
the people doing the shooting in some
cases they are these defendants
but in some cases they're not the idea
here is to put on trial the responsible
parties
but the nature of the trial again
differs from the imt
if the trump were gary and spear and the
rest of those people none of them ever
killed anybody with their hands
there are people in an office that are
ordering the killing of others
the people in this box these 24
are there
they're at the sites they're at the pits
later when they start their experimental
using gas fans to murder people they're
there
and that's the difference
where and again it just it really
puzzles me again that people know about
the one trial and they don't know very
much about the trial where the actual
killers
are being brought to justice
the defendants in this case are again an
interesting mix they're atypical
their defenses break down into three
rough categories
about
a third each the math is not perfect but
that's that's close enough
a third of them are going to justify on
the witness stand exactly what they did
and they're going to tell you what they
did
they're not going to hide from it
they're not going to quibble about
numbers absolutely that that's what's in
the report that's what we did
and so forth
some of them will say that they did it
this is the justified group because it's
well known that
bolshevism or communism is a mortal
threat to germany
it's well known that all that all
communists are jews
and therefore it is perfectly legitimate
to kill them as sort of a preventative
measure before they can destroy germany
when specifically asked about well how
can you then justify killing women and
children the answer is well they're
going to grow up and seek revenge
so our action is perfectly justified if
your ideology is is on this track
others will say well
defensive of necessity i that case or
self-defense
if i didn't carry out this order i would
be arrested or killed
you know there's not one instance of
anywhere of that ever happening
germans actually in the 70s they went
back and they looked at it at
court-martial records there's not a
single case where anybody on any iss
group or unit ever
asked to be let go and was punished
because some people did ask to be let go
so that also fails
or
if i didn't do it they would bring in
somebody even worse
it's extraordinary but that's what they
did
group two the deny group
uh wasn't me i didn't do it i wasn't
there the numbers are wrong
you can't prove i was there i was on
leave when that bad stuff happened
just flat out deny
if you've got a document somebody's
that's not right that was just somebody
boasting that didn't really happen
so flat out not going to cooperate not
admitting to anything olendorf by the
way is very very vocally in the first
group
here's what i did here's why i did it
that's it
group three is in some ways more
interesting group three is
people that will grudgingly
to some degree admit what they did but
there seems to be some sort of conflict
some of them kind of have a
late case of remorse
some of them not all of them
and they're difficult to fathom it could
be very very easily a trial strategy
because this worked really well for
albert spare in the main trial
spare famously copped to you know i
really feel guilty and terrible about
what i did and what was done and the
spear saved his life
when he probably should have hanged
but in this case
there's one of the worst offenders at
the iron zest group of case is a is an
officer named powell bloble
global is the
person who masterminded the baba yara
massacre
in 1941 33 000 people were killed over a
period of two days
he is
an unrepentant killer
in a sense
he suffers from severe alcoholism
he's suffering evidence of
personality disintegration by the time
we get to this trial
after the iss group of units are wound
up
he's sent back into occupied russia to
burn the evidence of their crimes to
destroy the physical remains
and he really is is somebody if you had
to pick somebody in a poster for needs
hanging bloble's probably a good guy
[Music]
ironically when the decision comes out
we'll get to that here in a bit
the group the second group the deniers
none of them got the death penalty
turned out to be a pretty workable
strategy and because it seemed clear
that
again mike musmano is is the driving
force of the judges
to him he needed a confession
he needed you to admit on the stand that
yes i did it yes this is accurate yes
this is true and only in that way
because he'd actually been a death
penalty opponent before the trial
kind of turns into one again after the
trial
so i think in his own mind that he could
only justify giving a death sentence to
somebody who flat out admitted it
the evidence against every one of these
defendants is overwhelming whether they
admitted it or not
and think about how fun the justice
system would be if you had if you could
only send us people that were said they
did it
again olendorf
is the star
and
as a prosec again even as the defendant
in the case he's acting more like a
prosecution witness
uh he will testify against the others
and and if they say something that's
wrong you can call olandorf back up to
rebut the testimony
the rules of evidence at the int as well
as this trial are whatever the trial
judge says they are
there is no written guideline you can
only admit evidence under these
conditions or with this authentication
it is whatever the trial judge
determines to be relevant
so if you want you can bring allendorf
back a lot
and they do
because he's a perfect witness he's a
weird man
and there's a little bit more weirdness
coming from him
after eight months of testimony
when this case finally wraps up
uh the
the the written opinion of this
that mike muzmano writes and if you read
a lot of mikey musemano stuff this is
him writing the case again the other two
guys i don't know what they're doing
during the writing phase but they're not
they're not doing this
he's remarkable
penguin stuff aside i mean this is a guy
who actually seems to get it and
understand why it's important and gets
the right words to explain to other
people why it's important
defenders are not charged with you know
planning or
killing through channels or sitting in
an office
they're in the field taking an active
part
in the bloody harvest and that's exactly
what this is
these are guilty people the evidence
overwhelmingly proves them to be guilty
and at least some of them are are going
to get sentences commensurate with that
level of guilt
but not everybody
when the verdicts delivered
a 10th of april 1948
out of 22 defendants and again we
started with 24 because
24 chairs
one of them had committed suicide
one guy had severe parkinson's disease
and he had kind of a wig out when they
were doing the reading the indictment so
they did they shunned him aside
so we proceed with 22.
20
and you're accused by the way on three
counts i should have said that earlier
war crimes crimes against humanity
and membership of a criminal
organization
the int which is again a remarkable
trial and i hope maybe he asked me back
to talk about that sometime
said
that organizations just like people can
be guilt can be determined to be
criminal
so at the int they declared the sd which
is the parent organization of the
einsatzgruppen
part of the ss the gestapo
the nazi party leadership and so forth
to be criminal organizations
that decision is final as of 1946.
so all you have to prove at this trial
by the way if you want to convict
somebody in count three let me see your
membership card and you're guilty
one war crimes two crimes against
humanity what's eventually going to
evolve after the war into genocide
20 of these people are guilty in counts
one two and three
two people are guilty only on count
three because the the trial judge
determined their participation was did
not rise to the
level of guilt on count one and two
14 out of 22 were sentenced to death
two get life
five get in prison for anywhere between
10 and 20 years
one person has sent us the time served
because really it was
probably
he wasn't the best defendant in the
world to pick but hey you got to fill 24
seats so you know you get who you get
and here's the weird part
olendorf the ss general
who started the ball rolling on this
thing back at the imt trial
after he ascendants to death
he continues to go to other trials to
testify there
for the prosecution
after he's gotten a death sentence he
will volunteer to go testify in
other other cases one of the other
subsequent nuremberg trial cases
and it's hard to get your mind around
that but it seems pretty clear that
olendorf thought like some criminal
defendants now the more they talk the
better chance they have of convincing
you what what they did was right
people under interrogation do that all
the time you get people that you can't
shut them up because they really are
convinced that that's the more they talk
the more you're going to believe them
and he continued to do this
for years
very up front very accurate
and he's guilty as hell
the problem with the einstein's group of
case and maybe
maybe there are a couple of problems
uh
i recommended a book to you earlier
which is ordinary men by christopher
browning i'm going to recommend a movie
to you now a lot of you probably seen it
if you have go see it go get it see it
again if you haven't seen it go see and
go watch it
call judgment at nuremberg with spencer
tracy
i show it every year i can watch it all
day there's a great line in the movie
where a reporter is talking to one of
the the generals
and the reporter says that you know i
couldn't give away a story on the
nuremberg trials right now
and he's right
because what's happening at the same
time that this verdict is being
delivered in 1948
the world has shifted
nazi crimes and and and and that period
have started to
to become secondary
what's become primary
is the soviet union
the reconstruction of europe the
marshall plan which is going to come
into effect soon
as soon as the verdicts are let down and
again you got 14 death sentences out of
this case
people are tripping over themselves
americans and then eventually germans
into trying to get these sentences
dismissed reduced nullified
the americans are under the impression
that you're not you're going to make the
german people unhappy if you if you keep
sentence more of their leaders to death
that it's time to for to almost not
forget exactly but it's time to focus on
new priorities
uh conrad ottenauer who is the the
chance new chancellor of germany makes
it a specific point
that if the allies want german
cooperation one of the things you're
going to have to do is start remitting
and start reducing these war crime
sentences
clear choice you want germany modern
reorganized federal republic of germany
in 1949 uh this is what you're going to
have to do
so where is general taylor
is aghast at this and ben ferenz is
aghast at this
it's exactly what happens
and as 1948 goes into 49 and 50 and 51
by the time we get to 51 we've reduced
14 death sentences to four at landsberg
prison
so all those other people sent us to
death for all those
million murders
in places like fineza
and other places where we don't even
they don't even have names
little jewish communities where
everybody has been killed and by the way
that's one of the other reasons that
fairness decided not to put on any
witnesses
there weren't any victims left to
testify
when the is grouper comes into town they
kill all of all of you
that that goes away
and new justice new reconstruction
justice kind of takes its place
and one of the things ironically that
olendorf kept thinking
was i'm an economics expert i know the
russians i fought the russians or at
least fought on you know murdered people
on the russian front
surely the allies are going to want to
take advantage of my expertise
he
doesn't miss it by much
and
come to a second because i want to talk
about what the trials mean or they don't
mean
olendorf though did miss the train when
it left the station
because in 1951 he is one of the four
people that's put to death hanged at
landsberg prison
along with powell bloble the guy that
orchestrated the babajira massacre
nobody misses him
one of the other defendants sentenced to
death is a colonel
named martin sandberg soundbreaker
stephen martin sandberger
evidence of the einsteins group of
reports and the jaeger report put his
personal tally of his his sunder
commando which was a sub-unit of
einstein's group a
and about 20 000 people
uh he operated actually he lost he
lasted in the east longer than most of
the other ss leaders he volunteered to
stay longer
he sent us to death
in 1948
his sentence is
reduced
from a death certain death sentence that
probably would have been carried out if
it had happened during the imt trial
he actually served six years
he died five years ago
at a retirement home in stuttgart
he drew a state pension every month
until the day he died
after the war his law license which by
the way wasn't suspended he's a lawyer
or was a lawyer
he got work with a german
concern and he made a bunch of money
and people just forgot about him
german magazine der spiegel interviewed
him a couple of months before he died
and he remembered some things with
incredible clarity that had nothing to
do with the murders
but when it came to murders this is a
picture that spiegel took when they
interviewed him at the bottom right hand
side
yeah he he just he couldn't seem to
recall those kind of details
if we look at this case in this series
of cases as kind of an outlier
that this is something that they did
to innocent people i think you were
probably missing the boat on that one
uh in 1962-63
a doctorate yale stanley milgram
conducted an interesting series of
experiments on obedience to authority
you probably heard about them
amazingly
few people
younger people now no one has heard
about these hardly unless you study
psychology
and the point here is if you can take
average ordinary american citizens that
are going to work for you know
one of the fee was four dollars
in 1962
uh put you in a room with a a person and
you conduct experiments in reinforced
learning
you ask the person who strapped up to
this device with electrodes some
questions
if they get them right that's great you
ask them another question but if they
get it wrong you're supposed to flick a
switch and send an electrical current to
them to help reinforce their learning
the box you're attached to or the box
you're operating is marked from like
level one to lethal level
50.
how many people do you suppose would
continue to administer electric or what
percentage of people you suppose would
continue to administer electric shocks
all the way to a lethal level
well the experiment was conducted in
6263 it's been reproduced a number of
times in a number of different locations
and the numbers are pretty consistent
just over half of the people tested
will continue if the person in the lab
coat tells you to flick the switch
and these aren't nazis 70 years ago
these are our people right now
i
it's it's a really disturbing study and
the fact is i think if you conducted it
a new one now and you started changing
the math a little bit
and you had people
administering shocks and by the way this
is of course a setup we're not really
electrocuting people it's they're actors
the person who's flicking the switch
doesn't know that but if you try to do
it again now
and suppose you had them administering a
learning reinforcement test to a group
of people that they may not like very
much
what do you suppose what happened
if you made them different if you made
them other
if you don't give somebody you know
ideological conditioning to get them to
hate or to to to have
the sort of the depth
of
dismissal
that the ss had for the people that they
killed
i think we would be very shocked by this
and it really isn't i think a 70 year
old thing i think it's very much the
fact that if if you really want to you
can talent spot for good stuff
and i think you can talent spot for evil
if i work with a group long enough i can
pretty much pick if i really want to
have something done
i i can probably identify who that who
those people are going to be likely that
will do it
and that's and that's the frightening
part to me about this trial
the legal part i i get completely the
other part i may never get this and and
i probably i don't know that i maybe i
shouldn't get it
but if we walk away in thinking that
this is a something in the past it isn't
if you look even going back to those
three kinds of defenses we saw in the
iss group in case
if you pull the statements of the
perpetrators of the melaye massacre
or if you look at the investigations
that were conducted in rwanda
they're the same
yes i did it and i was justified in
doing it no i didn't do it and you can't
prove that i did
or i kind of did something but i'm
really not gonna not gonna be very
forthcoming about that
there isn't there is no distinction and
it doesn't matter it doesn't have
anything to do with nationality or
religion or race i think probably the
fact is it's just it's
around and maybe the better question is
is there a way to short circuit that
which is probably another talk for
another day
so if we're looking at the trial
how did we do
the sad truth is
trials
by their very nature aren't supposed to
produce
justice
i'm probably going to get like pelted by
lawyers for that but they don't
[Music]
trials produce a result
you get guilt and innocence in this case
you get guilt
guilt
you get clarity you get some historical
truth you get a record of what actually
happened but whether or not these trials
the nuremberg main trial or any of the
subsequent trials
the doctor's trial the e-gay firearm and
trial whatever produced justice
i think only is known after the trial is
over
it offends me as as a lawyer and as a
person that martin sundberger was able
to live the rest of his life on a
pension and nobody cared about it
that doesn't seem to me to whatever
notion of justice you carry i think
that's probably not close to it
but the trials are important and i can't
even imagine
where we would be in terms of in many
fields if we hadn't had them if we
hadn't produced the evidence because
this stuff didn't come out during the
imt
if we'd stopped after the main trial
the picture we would have of what went
on in world war ii would would be so
incomplete it's you can't even calculate
it
so this did matter
and i think that
if there's ever a lawyer's hall of fame
and there ought to be we need to get
some funding for that so you need to
start hitting people up you know okay so
get you know get on that
telfer taylor needs to be in it and ben
ference needs to be in it
um because i think they did the best
they could under incredibly adverse
circumstances
with something that really does
qualitatively
matter
and it should matter
what you got
yes ma'am
because we are filming tonight's program
for national television we would ask
that you please step to the microphone
in the middle of the room so that we can
capture your question for television
viewers so as you have questions please
head to the microphone and dr hall will
hopefully be able to answer them
or not so much and we'll find out okay
first of all i'd like to thank you for
your presentation because it was very
informative and that type of information
um
is not put out to the public too often
and it's really important because people
have short-term memories
the other thing that i wanted to ask you
a question is a friend of mine
was looking up something and she
accidentally got on this website where
they had all sorts of um
theories and one of the theories that
they discussed was that there wasn't um
six million jews killed they had like
eight eight hundred thousand and they
were saying that you know this could not
be proved and that was greatly
exaggerated et cetera et cetera et
cetera so my question is as you put down
obviously there is some proof of some
jews that were executed do you know what
the tally that we can say for sure that
we know this many we might not know you
know eight million six million but we
can say for certainty that this number
is killed and we can extrapolate the
rest it's it's hard i think that kind of
precision probably is beyond us with the
einsatz group i can you can say with
pretty high degree of confidence what
the number is
with the concentration camps oftentimes
the prisoners are brought in they're not
entered into the camp records they're
sent immediately to extermination
so so the exact total
assuming it ever existed might have been
with the railroad system in terms of how
many people are put on what kind of
transport
but this is such a comprehensive
biological extermination it's happening
with these mobile extermination squads
it's happening
with
einstein's group a one of the one of the
things they had going for them was the
degree of help they got from local
people that are already you know
spun up to to kill people
uh the commandant of auschwitz testified
at nuremberg that that his camp
had killed he said about two million and
i think that was probably a little bit a
little bit too high for auschwitz not by
much but a little bit
shorter answer is we don't know okay and
we're never going to know and i
i i think kind of going back to one of
the things that most mono said in in the
decision
the inability of our minds to to absorb
and to get around these kinds of numbers
i'm not even sure certainly would help
out with that
but by the way and it really disturbs me
that people
would start to quibble that it's only
eight hundred thousand i mean for crying
out loud if you got olendorf who's been
sentenced to death that's still telling
you
here's what we did
okay you know
that's true good point thank you yes
ma'am
and by the way nobody that i work with
is allowed to ask a question okay
because
they they may not they're actually very
mean to me during the work day and i'm
not i'm not going to give them a
platform here
hi
can you speak to why the nazis
quit using employing the einsteins group
and and shifted their tactics
to
the death camps simply because it was
inefficient
uh the germans again
i think the better model of the
holocaust is kind of an evolving
thing the plan to do kind of universal
biological extermination i think
probably happened after the german
invasion of russia
their inclination was
fits and starts and there wasn't there's
not really a straight line holocaust
story
once they got into russia and the jewish
populations were were much larger that's
when i think the izats group were
deployed and the need to kill these
people
but they weren't enough
and even even inside a highly
indoctrinated nazi system you're not
able to pony up enough people to do this
by bullets
so they started to express 1942 they
start experimenting with gas vans
and they realize that actually that in
some cases is harder on the the the
attendance the the the ss than even the
shooting
so they got to come up with another
system
and so
after reinhardt heydrich is killed in
1942 they set up a number of just purely
extermination centers
was partially extermination partially
a main camp with different chemical
companies or different industrial firms
that worked at auschwitz
those camps are purely they have no camp
population
they're purely to get people in to to to
exterminate them and to dispose of the
bodies
and that is a difference that happens
really in 42 that that even wasn't true
with the iss group
okay
[Music]
how many questions can i ask you
she's a lawyer which means you should
not trust her
not at all
um i'm curious as to and i i don't
didn't recall i didn't really study
these trials so i don't know but who
determined the statutory structure what
the crimes were were going to be um what
the elements of those crimes were going
to be
the fact that there really were no rules
of evidence um who made those
determinations the termination happens
pretty late it's in june 1945 so the war
has just ended okay the warriors in
europe in may in nineteen in june 45
that was called the london conference
russians british french americans get
together and over about a three week
period they hash out what's going to be
the nurnberg trial policy
the nuremberg charter
all
32 articles of it i thought i'm sorry i
can't remember how many articles it
specifies here's how the trials are
going to work and one of them is
relevance is the only standard that
matters
i think article 17
how did they select the judges why would
they pick somebody who was an opponent
of the death penalty
by 1948 that's another problem because
again the world had kind of moved on by
then they had trouble recruiting judges
the
judges at the nurburgring tribunal were
in some cases the best they thought they
could get the main trial
in this case they wanted people that
would do it
which was hard finding people that would
actually volunteer to spend maybe a year
trying a case
uh they needed people that knew how to
write an opinion which an army army in
the army procedure you don't normally
write opinions
so it had to be a civilian jurist that
would do it
sometimes you get what you get
some of them were offense phenomenal
jurists
the
judge
spite from alabama we had never been a
judge before
okay and then finally i'm assuming that
they had defense attorneys yes um
i can't think of a worse job to have but
i do believe that in due process who
were they and
how did they get selected
they volunteer their fees were paid by a
number of different organizations the
americans would pay for for a defense
attorney um
there's one guy named rudolph oshnower
who represents i think a hundred and
something war criminals over the course
of his career some of them were very
very good but the thing is the german
system is not like this anglo-american
system we have at the imt
so they had to get smart about that fast
some did some didn't
they did have army lawyers available too
by the way to kind of to coach them they
get any civilian lawyers to do that the
german almost i think in every case
except one all the german lawyers were
civilian lawyers they didn't get any
they didn't get any u.s civilian
attorneys
all right
does that end the question and answer
session if the mic is
[Music]
can you comment on the fact that while
these trials were ongoing in europe
the oss and the cia here in america
we're bringing over
men who were
commit who had committed equally heinous
crimes
ostensibly to try to use them to
for questionable
intel and they
discovered that they didn't have much to
tell them and then they set them free
and they live next door sometimes a
block away from their uh victims yeah
the oss cia plan is called operation
paperclip
they brought over
i don't think anybody knows how many uh
people who have worked for the ss or the
gestapo or work for the german
government whose professed knowledge
about the soviet union was considered to
outweigh their their
criminal past
uh
there are a lot of different examples
klaus barbie actually who was the
butcher of leon he was he was later
convicted um
he worked for the americans
we brought over rocket scientists in
some cases we're not too
we weren't too particular about the ones
we brought over
but against part of the same pattern
that after the war is over political
priorities shifted
and and again you get the result you get
thank you yes ma'am
i guess that's my question is more about
the political priority so what do you
think would have happened
if we would have continued the allies
in enforcing the death sentences and not
backing away from it
you said german the chancellor said he
wouldn't participate explain to me what
you think that would have looked like
the issue in in in sort of the the late
40s is german sovereignty with the issue
we wanted to bring germany back as a as
a nato or eventually not quite yet nato
but as a bull work against the soviet
union
which was an active threat the berlin
blockade you know and so forth
um
and that simply was one of the
priorities in other words to turn the
process as much as possible back over to
the germans
so we needed their economy to be strong
we needed their economy to be strong we
needed a political infrastructure a
political infrastructure that was was
was not nazi
because at the same time we've been
doing a
expansive like denosification program
so as quick as we could we're trying to
sort of get out of that business turn
any prosecution of war criminals over to
the new german government
the problem is and we have the same
thing this is not a german specific
issue
people trying their own
does not go well
uh
you know i mentioned the miley case from
1969
uh the
we seem incapable of actually handing
out you know
reasonable sentences to people of our
own that commit crimes
there's a famous trial that goes on in
leipzig after the first world war in
1922 where the germans are asked to put
german citizens on trial for war crimes
in the first world war
there's out of a list of 900 suspects
i think 12 go to trial
of the 12
two of them escape under circumstances
that are kind of peculiar like they just
went to their house and they just
weren't there and we don't know where
they've gone and so they're dropped
none of them serve longer than four
years
because it's you get into really some
some really hinky issues once you start
asking people to pass judgment on their
own when you still have what you
consider you know
occupying forces in your country
so was our ability to impose conditions
non-existent too like for example okay
they're going to be sentenced that may
be short in their sentences i assume
that happened too and now they can't
hold positions in government like were
there conditions we could put in well no
because eventually there's going to be
just just a general amnesty
the last of the nuremberg defendants and
we convicted
185 out of the out of the 12 trials
the last custodial sentence ended in
1958.
uh it you know that's one of the the
kind of shocking statements if you're
seeing the movie judgment at nuremberg
for the first time is a little caption
at the end that says none of them are
still serving their sentences
and the idea is that you
uh the the best face i can probably put
on it is to say that it's it's not our
optimal outcome
thank you yes ma'am
[Music]
anybody else
thank you seriously for your attention i
really
[Applause]
as well as the truman presidential
library and the truman center and the
midwest center for hall of health
education coming together this evening i
know dr hall will still be around if you
have some additional questions and i'm
sure he'd be happy to
answer them or try to answer them thank
you for being with us this evening and
please come back and join us again in
the future
[Applause]
you're watching american history tv